اسمع ، أعلم أن هذا كان صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة
لك يا أخيك والدتك ، لا يمكنني إلا أن
أتخيل
أنك تعرف الآن
مكانه وأتساءل عما
سمعته عنه
منذ أن تم
وضعه في هذا السجن بما في ذلك من
خلال محاميه الذين اتصلوا
به
نعم  تم نقل والدي إلى
سجن حراسة مشددة جديد أكثر بعدًا ،
ولم يخطر أحد المحامين أو
الأسرة بنقله ، وهذا
بالطبع مثير للقلق للغاية لأنه
شخص لواحد مع الأشخاص نفس
الأشخاص في نفس الحكومة  الذي
حاول قتله في عام 2020.
شاهدناه في وقته السابق
في السجن حيث أصبح
مريضًا
ونحيف المعاملة الرهيبة فقط
ما نعرفه عن الظروف في
هذا السجن الجديد
والظروف في السجن هي
سيئة وبعيدة عن ما تفكر به
السجون النموذجية عندك تعرف المكتبات
وأه المعدات الرياضية
هذا من أخطر
السجون أه وأشهرها حراسة مشددة في روسيا
والمعروفة بتعذيب وقتل
النزيل  قاموا
بتسييج
ثكنة منفصلة في المنطقة
لإنشاء سجن داخل السجن
بحيث لا يستطيع التحدث
علنًا وعزله عن أي
معلومات
لا يسمحون له بالذهاب إلى أي مكان
لا يُسمح للناس بالتواصل معه
و  هذا النوع من العزلة هو في الحقيقة
تعذيب نفسي محض لأي شخص